《红楼梦》第五是回《如雪安连诗》。在这场诗社活动里,林黛玉身上有一些亮点格外值得注意。当种子媚连诗完毕,大家商量做梅花诗识,使湘云抢得要做,被削保柴敢忙蓝住。在这个情况下,林黛玉提了一个很关键的建议,援助记。
《红楼》,我先做一首,保柴忙导,今日断胡不容你在做了,你都抢了去,别人都闲着也没去,回来还发宝玉,她说不会连句,如今就叫她自己做去,待遇孝道这话很识,我还有个主意,方才连句不够,末若减着连得少的人做红梅。
使湘云诗识疯子,待着机会就要做诗,当天学中连诗读他连的最多,一人连了十几句,可未是大出疯头,正因此,削保柴不让他再做,转而让假保预作,林黛玉却觉得今日连诗大家的表现真词不齐,有连诗极多者,如使湘云削保琴以及自己,
总有一些姐妹,因为性格因素,或休口难言,不擅长争着做诗,为了让他们也有展现自我的机会,待遇才提出这个建议。
这个建议,若是出自削保柴之口,便着实寻常,毕竟保柴原本就是个细心体贴之人,可从林黛玉口中说出来,就格外惹人注目。
因为通过这个建议,能看出来,林黛玉,早已不是以前的林黛玉了。
诸君请看原住第十八回,原非醒清一节,假原春令诸子妹每人做一首印志诗,期间林黛玉的反应,十分轻高孤傲,风忙碧漏。
假非看碧,称长一番又笑到,中世学林二妹之作与众不同,非与子妹可同列者。
原来林黛玉安心经业大展棋材将重人压倒,不想假非指命一边一勇,倒不好维语多作,只胡乱做一首五言律应景罢了。
曹雪琴还专门提醒读者,林黛玉做的是五言律,而细查其他姐妹,如保柴,李丸,假家三言者,做的都是七言识。
看似林黛玉闭重旧清,专门简简单的五言识来做,有逃巧的嫌疑,实责林黛玉非不能做七言,乃因一人一手不能十分畅意,未发泄心中不满,故意以五言律色责。
更惊人的是,尽管黛玉此首诗有应付的嫌疑,却仍然压倒重姐妹,得到原非的亲口称赞。
其后林黛玉见家宝玉才思哭解,便又站出来冲当枪首,替她做了一首幸连再望。
许多读者将其认为是林黛玉深爱宝玉的旁征,这自然不为错,但按照具体情景,林黛玉当枪首的直接心理,恐怕还是因为当天做失没有过意。
原非制定的一人一贬一勇,让她未能随心畅意的做失。
为了让一出的财气有处清洩,便一灰而救,替家宝玉做了这首幸连再望,再次收获原非的好评。
原非平定,幸连一手,乃宝玉四手终之最悠者,林黛玉之勇序之才令人扎舌。
林黛玉的财气一直衡扫家伏,除虚保拆,可与她征衡之外,几无对手。
甚至连假证都对拆带两人撑散不已。
到了第38回,橘花施赛,林黛玉更是连选,勇局问局局梦三手施,义股作弃拿下橘花施赛的前三米。
故地38回,张回名为,林销销葵夺橘花施。
如果说原非醒清,和橘花施赛中的林黛玉是争着索施,那么如雪安连时中的林黛玉则实上施。
将永红梅花这个记应请又好写的诗题,让给那些没有表现机会的姐妹。
这一征一让之间,就能看出林黛玉性格的成长。
藏风影制,从以自我为中心,到故权他人感受的自我退变。
从功论来,林黛玉的这个建议也很重要。
因为施设活动的基础是人,我们要让每个人都参与其中,人人都有娱乐收获感。
若是不顾及那些,财司词顿,修口难言之人,他们就会喪失对施设活动的兴趣,慢慢轮为边缘人。
在之前的施设活动中,这个问题就曾切切实实的出现过。
当初,秋爽摘欧杰海唐社,设章理完就忽略了这个问题。
他将英春西春设指为副社长,一个出题线运,一个腾路坚长,说白了就是两个虚显。
后续的施设活动里,出题线运根本轮不到英春。
在场做事的人都是自家姐妹,哪里会有人作弊,根本不需要坚长。
正因为这个设置的缺陷,后来,英春西春基本等于退出了施设。
西春早早就借着给假母化年华的机会,一开口就是一年的假,这等于退出施设。
第49回,保育看春,商议,学下做事。
看春说,要等二姐,英春病好了再办。
假保育却说,二姐姐又不大做事,没他又何访。
可见副社长虚显,让英春也脱离了施设活动,长期缺乏参与感,有他没他区别都不大。
可能也是基于这个前车之间,林代域才会提出,让连诗少的人做红梅诗。
如此一来,他们得到参与感以后,就能放得更开,之后的施设活动也会进行的更加顺畅。
其实和指林代域,大官员的姐妹们帽子都发现了这个问题。
我们看录学案连诗的默误,最终收尾时,离完连了一句,预制精招乐,理期收了一句,平时注顺游。
其实林代域,虚保猜,虚保情使相云,这些人在场,他们若要抢着收尾,哪里能轮得到理事姐妹。
尤其是理期,在整个连诗过程中,他只连了可连的一句。
其后做红梅诗,离完又说,其二不大会做,还是让秦妹妹做吧。
可这位实在不擅长做事的理期,却承担起连诗收尾的工作。
很显然,是大家故意让他加入进来,不至于成为诗设的隐形人。
小小的一个连诗活动,却能收尾相连,串连起红楼梦前后多篇文字,可见其魂然一体,
红楼能经得起细品的原因,就在于此。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。